hi rich how are you well Dan I'm here in
my office at the the Rich Eisen show in
El Segundo and I came to work today and
I had this metal briefcase placed here
thanks to you it was a gift to me and I
haven't opened it yet but man advance
what's in it you know what I want it to
be a surprise
but ok 13 other of my closest friends
got those briefcases if that right yes
we what do you think of George Clooney's
move there that that he this happened
three years ago where everybody gets a
million dollars who's one of his boys
there
of course it's that's good stuff man I
mean it's absolutely great stuff right
there
I'm wondering because I heard you
talking about obviously on the way and
do you think because you know obviously
Randy Gerber said that they paid taxes
on it do you think there's some a member
of the Internal Revenue Service that was
listening that's just let's see if that
actually how do you think they're sure
he's actually on the case right now oh
yeah oh yeah absolutely wrecked in the
math absolutely absolutely I want you to
weigh in on you get one album only one
album to listen to the rest of your life
oh my gosh so I'm gonna go one with
volume
I'll go white album okay well it was
taken by me but oh really yes off you
say that yeah I didn't know that yes
honestly that I did not know you must
have talked about that in the first
Alice I did um how about Joe Walsh's
Greatest Hits
no you can't do it Greatest Hits why not
I got rules here rich we got standards
here you can't do a greatest hits
compilation and the white albums already
taken why had no idea that the white
album was already taken
how about born in the USA then you drink
steam that you can have that that's you
thank you yeah sold I will take that did
you introduce Springsteen when he was
there I'm telling how was it good it was
great I mean it's royalty man he didn't
know much football
you know the the the halftime act that
I've been fortunate to interview that
knew the most believe it or not that
blew me away was Mick Jagger for Super
Bowl 40 in Detroit and he actually knew
speaking of Hines Ward he actually knew
the storylines describing how the
Steelers are a team that's been there
before but they have this young
quarterback who sort of is a guy who's
trying to make sure that he doesn't turn
the ball over he basically described Ben
Roethlisberger as game manager which he
was if you recall back prior to Super
Bowl 40 and how the other team had a
really good running back and they you
know they're there he likes their story
because they haven't been a Superbowl
before and I'm like Jesus explaining
Alexander and the Seahawks that was wild
Springsteen didn't know that much about
it but we just went over his setlist and
what he you know what this meant to him
and you know coming from Staten Island
that that's that's royalty right there
in Springsteen yeah I'm thinking you
know he's a Jersey guy that that he
would be brought I know he's a Yankee
fan but I'm surprised he didn't know
didn't follow the NFL fantasy league man
you know he wasn't in that one you know
the the E Street Band fantasy league I
guess didn't exist but why met Dave
Matthews in Matthews he had you know I
was in a movie with him with Sandler but
he had no idea who I was and and so I
went to see him in concert and he said
here let me take you to somebody who's
gonna appreciate you being here and he
opened the door to his drummer and you
know so I I spent all he goes he goes
yeah hey Carter I got somebody to see
you opens the door and Carter goes hey
damn Patrick and then Dave Matthews goes
oh so you know who he is
all right you guys can talk because Dave
David he had no game yet he couldn't
even fake it he's like I I don't know
any sports here I don't I don't know any
Berman Berman never got that treatment
no no he did not hey I went down a
permit I went down a Behrman wormhole on
the air last week on game day morning
because of Adam Thielen doubt that he
would have been like the perfect Berman
nickname guy this year Furman was doing
his gig as he has the last few years you
know what do people miss him just Adam
hooked on a feelin peaceful easy feeling
Adam feelin alright I just couldn't stop
like a full hour it was tough to get out
there are times when I'm doing
highlights where I channel him I you
know and then you just sort of morph
into this Jeju I don't think I don't
think this new generation
if you're under 35 understand the impact
of Chris Berman on highlights oh no you
know I I you know and Danny in a way
okay you know what you're doing on
Sunday nights on NBC is that's you know
that's primetime yeah I mean that's
that's what and it's great to see and I
think you know NFL Network has a show as
well we're doing highlights you know I
used to do that before the morning but I
still think a highlight driven show with
intelligent conversation laced in is I
don't know if I don't know if I'm a
dinosaur but I don't know why there's
not enough of those on TV anymore just
assuming you're gonna see if beforehand
you know on Twitter you're seeing it
online and it's not worthy of just
sitting down for an hour and creating a
television show that's entertaining it's
highlight driven I miss it I really do
well so we made a conscious effort to I
am one of the few hosts I don't know any
of the other hosts who do all the
highlights because you usually bring the
analyst in but the analyst isn't good at
doing highlights they're good at calm
many highlights not doing the highlights
I liked when Rodney and Tony interject
and they'll have like one line and then
they'll get out that that's you know a
conscious effort on our part to have a
little bit of fun say something and then
I'll get to you about the highlights you
just saw I don't want you doing the
highlights it's a lot more work for me
but it does bring me back to the Sports
Center days when I love that sort of
frenetic pace it's live TV and you're
doing these highlights and you get to
have a little bit of fun a little bit of
freedom so I have it any other way
I will I'm with you it's just it's a fun
watch certainly when my kids sit down
and watch uncle - well I've been
mentioning here's the poll question here
McLovin give Rich Eisen the poll
question here brought to you by HGTV if
you were Sam dartle of Josh rose and
knew the Browns were gonna pick you
would you go to the Browns go back to
school or publicly let it be known you
didn't want to be drafted by Cleveland
alright this is the annual this is the
annual conversation we've had now for
3-4 years and this is one of them okay
and the other one is wood wood the
Browns beat the best college and both of
them are just so just of course he's
going to the Browns he should go to the
Browns the Browns are why wouldn't you
go to the Browns I understand that
there's a graveyard of names but now you
can always be the one to change it look
at what LeBron has done with the tabs
why can't you decide that I'm one of the
best of all time
why can't you decide I'm the guy who's
going to change it all that's the sort
of attitude you need to have going into
the NFL you must and this day and age
back in the day where Eli said I don't
want to go to the Chargers and even you
know others before doing that those days
are over
they're over he should go to the Browns
and by the way the Browns would destroy
any of the teams that are in the college
football playoffs right now they
wouldn't even score a point maybe so I
hope they go to the Browns and I hope
that that's leading your poll thank you
rich McLovin give the results there
yeah the Browns are leading 39% then go
back to school 34% only 24% say let it
be known you don't want to go there
any of the dan Patrick I greatly
appreciate your audience is a reflection
of you and you're a reflection of your
audience and once again bring it all
thanks to the taste and you're welcome
to the cave enjoy enjoy thank you rich
RTP that's Rich Eisen NFL Network Rich
Eisen show comes up immediately after
this on audience gentle 239 that's
DirecTV for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]